imagine a place where you are welcomed
with open arms people don't judge you
but look to understand you validate you
for the special person that you are I
wake up in the morning like everyone
else but from there everything is just a
big difference I focus my body and my
mind on my goals and what I'm grateful
for in my life I don't work in an office
but my days can be 12 to 14 hours I have
a team behind me but at the same time
I'm a one-man army responsible for
hundreds of students dozens of helpers
and a handful of instructors my name is
Alex and here's a day in the life of me
I don't know if you noticed but I just
got super motion I was out sitting down
whatever go myself my seat of power like
Tony Robbins in LA what I think that the
thoughts of this thing where you sit
down and you do you think about three
things you're grateful for
pliny Malcolm Vega really makes cheer up
the most I spot about Iran Iraq salsa
and I thought about okay five motion
right now how grateful I am how my life
has changed because of it
the enemy was to think about three
things that you're going to do today and
already matches them as being complete
their duck or any taken care of right
supposed to motivate you tonight I
didn't worry about it or say things I
thought three things I'm going to talk
about this one crushing my class today
so I already have a plan as a music mix
out to meeting one that helpers around
2:30 a.m. walking her through and
mentoring for us so I'm excited about
that and doing the the fitness class so
I'm caught about it I'm like no it could
be another action-packed day 1214 hours
a lot of my days are like that but I got
my license already done so any props any
discussion
I find out having a structure into my
morning makes it easy for me to do the
recipe to deal with it I think it's
important that you have a morning
routine I think it's important that you
set yourself up you set yourself up for
success every day I think we've all had
these moments where we've been alive and
feeling great and want to felt boldness
we've all had these moments but it's not
consistent and so he's been
experimenting with this morning routine
Pepsi Co with strengthens on my Cub avid
right everybody has judges and it takes
away decision making any decision that
you do in your personalize anything each
weighs a little bit at your energy well
most people don't wake up energized and
like I'm going to tackle the day right
that's not how most people wake up and
get out of bed but we've all felt those
moments and when you're in that state we
feel unstoppable you're bold you want to
go and do really good things you'll do
things that you were afraid of doing
before
so our Monday's our RTDs eight now so we
started going over everything that's
happening to all the classes emails how
are the helpers assistant instructors
doing what's my progress like as an
instructor myself what am i learning
where am i pushing myself on and I'm
always you know asking for advice on how
to be a good leader
the previous owner Sharon I was training
under her as an instructor so you know I
first kind of got to know Alton who's in
my class I was teaching level six it's
our highest level class he's one of my
students and then he became a helper in
that class and he wouldn't listen the
feedback in class and I used to be
pretty cocky so whenever you would come
to me for it give me advice try to help
me about no no no I'm good I'm good and
my goals and instructors I want
everybody to get better
I'm with the students to get better I
want the helpers to get better my job to
meet everybody to improve and so I
walked in by and giving him feedback and
you didn't want to take it he kind of
always brushed it off like I think is
anything you want to do it wrong you do
it wrong whatever I don't
and I'm here to help you you don't want
to take it Jill wrong and then Sharon
the former owner of the business was
talking him wanted to make him an
instructor
Sharon calls me I'm doing my training
Chen called me she's like listen um I
have a back injury and cronic I can't go
and teach Evan has to come in he has to
take over and he'll try to find the
opportunity to teach and so I decide to
put him on the spot and you know what
sharing committed to this so I'm going
to follow through on it even though I
don't think he'll make a great
instructor let's see him let's give him
the chance
and we'll see so I go to pick up Evan
and he's like listen he's like I don't
need to learn anything you want to take
a chance I will let you teach the whole
class I will be on a side I will be
giving advice Allah teaches and I'm like
yeah I knew I wasn't ready yet yes I'm
not going to lose opportunity so I
started to do that and so what happened
was Evan was impressed at how how
quickly I was growing hard-working I was
and how quickly I would making key back
from him and over the course of that six
weeks he really impressed me of how much
he prepared how much he took the
feedback I gave him he's one of the
things is really good at it's taking
feedback now and when you tell him do
something because we'll apply it and try
it and see if it works for him and so
that was super helpful and helping him
become a really good instructor now he's
one of our best instructors and when I
was looking at somebody to help me so I
took over the business last year I was
looking to come to help me in running
the business I talked to Alex because
got a big heart he really cares he's
doing it for the right reason and so he
was a guy that I want to work with and
here we are a year later I can't even
imagine a fall back there's like there's
nothing beyond it like the I am I'm
going to crush this I'm going to just
like I'm going to change people's live I
don't need I don't need a plan B this is
the only planet I'll ever need Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday I'm with Evan
Friday Saturday Sunday I'm working on my
own and then backup Monday's with them
I'm here right at 9:00 or just before
9:00 we sit down and we break down all
of what's happening as idiot so going
over the progress of this
teachers assistant the school the
scheduling my personal growth what I'm
accomplishing where I'm falling short on
where I need to grow being around
someone who's such a hustler motivates
me to be a hustler - it's important for
anyone I think to have a good mentor and
to have great examples around you if the
people around you have high standards
for themselves if they are high
performers you're going to want to be a
high performer but if you're always
working with people you're around people
who are complaining who are just sort of
mediocre or okay and they're like all
life is this way whatever I've never
heard em instead life is like this is
like no we're going to change it it's
not good enough uh but yeah yeah we are
going to change it right that brings up
my standards
so I if anything is just like through
osmosis and seeing what he does I get to
absorb that and helps me along the
daytime it's pretty much a full day of
work there's always something to do
because if it's not planning what's
coming up the classes making sure all
the classes right now are okay the
numbers are bounce the payments are
going through all of that it's
continuous upkeep so you have rise in
the falls but that tends to be my day
I'm looking up quotes right to inspire
students to do that or I have to go and
I have to challenge someone on something
right something is happening I go find
out what was happening I got to try to
understand so there's a lot of that
happen - he came back from Mexico
wanting to who went to Mexico with a
friend of his and he came back having
this vision of him at the front of this
army being this general the front of an
army okay so what inspires that boldness
every day because that's what he watched
if you didn't want it then don't make
the environment to help you go and get
that but he wants it so it's one of the
things that we're working on the daleks
is okay what's the routine for you that
would make sense or in your world to get
deals just teach a little 6 and just
teaching Mondays not even long enough
you get good I think you'll lose it
really yeah if you wanted to
just be a manager and just be a coach
there is a different story if you want
to be a three bass instructor doing one
night a week is not going to be enough
mm-hmm yeah I didn't think about that
I wanted me okay it's the people who
complain that they don't get what they
want but then they don't match up the
behaviors that's the problem that I have
right and so if you look at Alex he
wants to do this thing you want to have
a big impact you want to lead this thing
forward you want to touch a lot of
people's lives and so his behaviors with
rising up to match it so I'm going to be
taking over more classes to teach now in
the evenings
Lily who's one of our senior structures
I want to connect with her I want to
give her a call actually and ask her if
she can take over something that I love
doing but I'm realizing if I continue
everything I'm going to burn out gonna
be tough in the tough at the beginning
because I'm doing Monday night Wednesday
night Thursday nights
basically most Uptown's I'm there so
like every other Friday at least I think
it maybe set up a capability to so she's
done that she did intermediate actually
but not just do the intermediate lesson
but to bleed the show mmm their show so
lily is one of our senior instructors
she's been instructor longer than me
about three years now and she's our soft
instructor and so she's a hustler she's
a grinders the hard worker passionate
love for students I think maybe maybe
even reaching out in the same looking
this is what the West Hills going nuts
yeah I want you know what I want to give
Lily the opportunity for the section
this is gonna be good for her too I'm
going to reach out to lily and see if
she's comfortable with taking over the
Friday night at least and so I train
enough assistance to be able to do some
of the days I'm doing that can go back
to doing the Friday's as well Lily
let's put on speaker hello hey Lily
hey how's Italy good how are you yeah
I'm just gonna go somewhere quick and
talk to you Oh Thank You Lily
yeah I wanted to ask you something I
wanted your thoughts so I'm going to be
taking over Wednesdays downtown on
Sundays today did it okay yeah yeah so
I'm going to be doing four days a week
I'm finding a bit of a challenge but
it's no obligation on you I don't want
to put any pressure on you but I'm
finding a bit of challenge of doing the
Uptown loss outing okay come here so I
wanted your thoughts if you feel
comfortable at least until I train and I
have someone take over the Wednesday
downtown for example okay um for you to
take over the Friday uptown moms okay
sounds good I'm up for the challenge
all right oh wow okay I uh right for me
it was actually be really good for my
own growth to I think that uh I think
that storytelling you being on a stage
in front I think that would really help
too
okay Lily so what i'll do is i'll i'll
message you in a bit we'll talk more
about it we'll talk about this friday
and how we can we can plan it out but
the thank you and i'm excited about this
the the growth for youtube okay sounds
good all right thanks Lily okay have a
good day
YouTube my god so that works better than
I thought it would um
how could I have conversation have gone
better I could have built that a better
value and opportunity I'm just shown
like the growth that I've gone through
and the benefit that she'll get um
instead of asking that it's a favor to
me yeah
I think that was the building of
clerical part of what have to get done
yeah and that we should to business to
do it without folks you know how much
you love doing it like it's hard you got
to let this go
yeah if I pass you like you want people
would be there do it why brings you joy
none of that is there just like another
chore that it done hmm yeah it's funny
to LA I don't want to give up by it I
rather give up the Saturday afternoon
side than Fridays it's the joy of dance
right but my model so my passion right
yeah cuz Sunday's for me is I'm not
really social dancing I'm not really
feeding that creative side of myself and
then timing is her what she wants to do
she wants to be a speaker she wants to
be able to ch1 and do storytelling why
faster the Nullification it's not trying
to convince you to do it it make sense
for her to do it if she has the time
because it's a good opportunity for her
yeah but if she doesn't want to do is
also other options
yeah she saw she's she's a smart person
yeah she saw so he's not looking to
convince her to do it does the
importance of that is you are looking
for opportunities of her support for
dreams this is what you want to do it's
not like I'm a failed job to think she
knows how it's going to help her put you
validate and recognize her messes
what her team is we'll find an
opportunity for her makes it more
important like that yeah I know it does
thank you mmm okay you guys go where I
found once ago yeah we have to go yeah
when he first started he was late for
everything and now he dedicated himself
to wanted to be 10 minutes early for
everything
and nobody would hold him accountable
people would say oh it's just Alex who's
friendly that's just Alex it's who he is
but it's not the Alex of Alex wants to
be he wants to be the leader he wants to
be the general and the leader isn't a
guy showing up ten minutes late so I've
been working really hard to hold myself
accountable and respect people's time if
I say I'm going to be there I'm going to
be there
I really don't have respect for my time
because what am i doing those 15 minutes
watching YouTube or wasting time on
something right as I'm as it is work and
then it's setting the right expectations
with people right so knowing this is
going to take an hour I'll see you then
this wall here is super important so
there's two parts to it actually we have
that huge family sign so the lights are
always on except during socials right so
we want to sort of a nice dark
atmosphere here but it's got a shot it
doesn't say salsa
it doesn't say dance it doesn't say
anything like that it says family so
when you come in here you should feel
like you belong you should feel like you
part of the community you're part of the
family because that's where it counts
and right under it what we have our
family tree so these are some of our
volunteers and instructors not all of
them but basically if they've been here
for a couple months we take their
picture we add it to the wall they put
their name
we put when they started all that and so
we're going to be adding more and more
pictures yeah and then we have this
beautiful space where people can come in
and feel comfortable have fun yeah so I
work here you want to shoot the video
let's do it all right originally why we
when we shall try to shoot the bio video
it was about five months into five six
five six months into working at CES and
my full-time job and we tried to shoot
the video but I was holding back on some
information and every time we do take
there was really no emotion to it and we
were trying to figure out why I'm
dancing why I started dancing why am i
teaching all these reasons and the
reason was because I had this huge
secret out I was holding on to and I
told them the actual reason why I
started salsa
holding back why I wouldn't share hey
guys my name is Alex I'm the director of
operations of Toronto dance awesome also
one of the instructors thank you so much
for watching my video I want to tell you
a little bit about myself when I was 12
years old I was diagnosed with
hyperhidrosis basically that meant my
palm was constantly sweat not only when
I would be nervous which is something
maybe you can relate to what my handlers
do know that is constantly what I'd be
writing at Ted I'd have to have my hand
off the paper I swear it leaked through
and makes a big run playing video games
with friends since I had them remoted be
soaking wet shaking hands and having
people go like this and just rub their
hand off just cost me from age 12 and
doctor said was puberty was this wasn't
going away so I was dealing with that
for ten years I so 22 I got tired I got
tired of being unhappy like that so I
was doing a lot of research and I found
out that there is a surgery to do just
stop your hands from sweaty
it was my it was it was the operation
the operation on my hand I was really
ashamed of it
he first thing he tells me is you got to
tell two people so it's been like about
a year of me telling the story to
everyone to my students is exciting
actually I'm ready I'm ready to tell the
real the real deal of how I started
dancing and everything everything that
happens it's not a safe procedure but I
was really adamant I really pushed that
I want to meet the doctor I went to see
my my family doctor I did all they
raising move the mountains and they
agreed to be the surgery for me it was a
pretty intense surgery they put people
to sleep they have to separate your rib
they go in they cut the connection to
your hand I remember when I woke up from
the the operation and they they asked
you to kill my hand or my hand play
and I thought my hand and I could feel
this tingling sensation I would get a
sinking sensation and my hands looks wet
I got the tingly sensation but there was
no sweat
that was really big yeah from 12 years
old to deal with that and then just wake
up after 10 years of that and just is
gone it's crazy
thank you so much for watching I'm
really excited about you joining our big
family and I'll see you in advance where
yes good okay hopefully she's ready
she's here so Christy has been a student
of ours for less than a year actually
and she's grown very quickly as a dancer
has a super positive personality so I'm
meeting her basically I made a
commitment that I'll meet every helper
at least one at the beginning to figure
out how it's going for them and then
figure out where I can serve them where
I can help them so I have I have these
weekly meetings with volunteers where I
offered them like help either in
personal development or dancing and
turns out meeting her just to see what I
can give back to her and help her with
so it's going to be us sitting down me
talking about myself why I started
getting to know her talking with her and
then big portion of it is going to be
we're gonna be sitting down and looking
at trying to figure out her one word her
core value that she stands for and then
from there how can she use that as a way
to measure her growth to help her guide
her in life to be to put herself in more
situations that are true to what she
stands for hey hey it's good are they
going great it's been crazy we doing a
lot of recording you want to you want to
hear a faster I know I know you're busy
got exams that are really appreciate you
coming yeah basically basically I want
it for you to really get to know me and
I wanted to get to know you and just
have a conversation where I can help and
I want to make sure that
I set people up for success because what
you realized and what you sent me seeing
in my classes I don't just teach moves
because not what it's about so there's a
difference between a teacher and a
leader right like and that that's what
matters and so what I'm trying to do it
with all the helpers also help them grow
as leaders because they all can make an
impact not only for others in the school
but in their live their family and in
themselves we all need that so that's
that's my responsibility too
sorry I'm getting emotional but it's my
responsibility to to make that happen
right and hopefully inspire people to do
the same it's weird
ah because we deserve that we deserve
that we deserve to be welcomed in we
deserve not to feel judged we deserve to
feel loved
and you have to set that standard you
have to set that standard and no matter
what people around you say or do you
don't bring your standards down because
of others you make others raise their
standards up and it's funny sometimes
being the right thing it just takes a
second of courage or doing the important
thing or making them or and making the
decision that's scary right now but pays
off in spades in the long run and you've
done the same thing I did sometimes just
say yes yes I'll do it and just you go
with it
[ __ ] you always grow from it I always
doubted myself and there was always
something I'm scared to fail or you know
if they'll do that and even like I said
stepping into salsa and they like to
know what I'm just going to let the
leader read me and I'm not going to want
to feel like I'm in control and like I
know what's going to happen in how I'm
going to succeed it's okay for most
isn't look at it's okay if you don't
fail you just die
get back up and scoot again try it again
you work at it and like I said those
kind of things that are most hitting
behind the vegetable dances itself I
think really helps people to grow and so
for me that inspires me at least and the
reason if anything your classes Wow so
it's more than just if you said the
moonset defense so that means a lot
thank you so here's the thing my one
word you know is belong I made a list of
things that make me really happy and
then I try to narrow down where Li
what's up my core like really what makes
it special for me what am I
either looking for what makes me excited
what makes me light up and there were
three words that stood out for me but I
had me see reason I was stuck and I was
like I'm like I can't figure out what my
core value is and so one thing that
makes me super emotional is Hercules the
Disney cartoon Hercules Michael Bolton
sings the main song for that movie is
called I can go the distance so I'm like
I need a break I need to put myself in
emotional standing two figures that's I
go listen to Michael Bolton and I'm
listening to us unless I'm getting
emotional and one of the things that
says I'm looking for a place where I
belong
[Music]
I'll be right we right below
soon as he said that word its trigger I
remember I started crying I look at this
list and there was this one word that's
like of the three like the belong was
like this is it and so I look at my life
and I realized that in high school
University I was always looking for a
place where I wouldn't feel judged so I
always had friends but I was one of
those people that I wouldn't always be
there I wouldn't be always invited so
when I saw this word belong it made me
look back at my past I feel like I was
always looking for that place
so for me that was that was the thing
that resonated with me and then I looked
at all my life and a lot of my decisions
and a lot of the times where I felt
awkward or didn't feel that it belong it
was always rooted in that one mistake
that I used to do is I would look in the
past I would say those things would
limit me those things crippled me they
didn't they made me stronger
and I choose list to live in the future
I choose to live in the present I'm not
going to live in the past now those
things won't change and so for me to
belong was a way to free that and then
push other people in to answer for you
freedom seems to be the way to go that's
what you're going to build your empire
on I think so it feels right okay okay
so um okay uh we'll wrap up I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get ready for the class I
got a fitness class today I got a
workout from five to six oh and then did
you teach for another zero yeah yeah
yeah yeah and low five well tell us see
how are you she reached out to me she's
asking for help she's doing on a project
she wanted someone to work with I said
yes you know what I'm gonna let's go
let's meet up let's go Kaufman let me
see what I can do to help she's not a
student of ours she didn't study in
university so we sit down we grab a cup
of coffee started talking and she
started interviewing me taking pictures
and I was like a full hour session of
why started dancing what I'm about and I
remember at the end of that interview
she said how important that interview
was for her there's so many schools she
reached out to so many people she
resolved so nobody would respond to her
and nobody reached out nobody replies to
her and she was about to give up on
everything
and so like she was grateful that I
respond and now she comes in and she's
gotta yeah she's got an exhibit I need
to say thank you because yeah I was very
helpful to like get so far Daniel that
means a lot and I may be a little old I
have you happen to are you free phone
well tomorrow I'm trying to think about
it actually is it an evening
well no it's like Costas for open to the
public so I will come information all
the course I'm going to have my snapchat
I'm gonna be snapping it up yeah look up
tomorrow it is an emotional Monday I
gotta say it's uh it's emotional Wow
holy cow okay I need to skid ready we're
going to be working out soon we got to
work out a five o'clock and then
teaching from 7:00 to 10:00 changing
lives I'm energetic I'm energetic hey
you guys been a crazy long day so far
it's only 4:17 I'm going to be coming at
you with a quilt in a second watch out
[Music]
watersense with Alec
it is such an amazing thing to be loved
for who you are
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
huh Monday hustlin got hot Souls a great
day workout then go chase come on
we finished the workout I am severely
lightheaded but I was worth it
here's the thing I've learned like the
dread of going to do something you don't
want to do like working out or whatever
it is whenever you finish it you have
such a good satisfaction especially
because you didn't want to do it so
always focus on the great feeling you're
going to have at the end of the workout
and not the workout or whatever it is
you have to do focus on the satisfaction
all it's already done
I think that's a really good lesson for
anyone right now
and you'll be surprised at how much
energy you actually have even as you're
grinding like losing five sets plus the
finisher I'm dying by the third and a
half set so I just keep going one more
one more one more one more push push put
and you get there and you got this tie
about you right I'm natural high you
have a high about you that you feel
amazing like a superstar and you have
more energy in the long run so even
though I'm tired right now when some one
o'clock hit all this adrenaline all the
power that's pounding through me right
now
I'm going to add more of that into the
class they're not going to see it coming
right now I'm so mellow though I need I
gotta go get some food I gotta eat
something but it's worth it it's all
worth it am i teaching soft at ten but I
don't stop until 11:30
yeah it's like 13 14 hours my days are
usually since saying wow but I love it I
would never change it for the world as
pursuit of happiness Alex is most
important role right now CBS is teaching
its that those three hours of he teaches
on a Monday night is super super super
important that's the chance room that
have the biggest impact we're all
running around we're trying to be but
don't forget we're still a family we're
together in this through and through
from beginning class to end ok 1 2 3 -
whoo there you go see ya now
isn't an amazing thing to be loved for
who you are that's the focus today and
it has a lot to do not only with the
love you give to others but you got to
love yourself to them as we're too hard
arms of them we're going to focus today
and some of the helpers when there to be
partner up with you when I'm you're
welcome I'm going to be walking around
it's not only going to be oh that's not
really good no it's going to be love and
care and be like yes you're going to be
great have fun smile so can we do now
can we make a commitment today to be a
loving caring and fun can we do that
it's Monday I wanted to have an amazing
time we are going to make a commitment
in this class that nothing outside is in
effect that this is our place to be who
you we are to be part of a family
recognizing the importance if you have
an ability here to touch a student's
life like the class and you put on today
could touch one of these students lives
and have a profound impact that could be
tonight that could be every single night
that Alec speeches right now I'm working
really hard to become a better leader
and to become the best instructor in
Canada to set a standard for every
instructor at our school and everywhere
what it means to be outstanding there's
nothing you want to change about
yourself
there you go feel that some are you
feeling amazing
yeah always oh I love that are we keep
discarding you're going to set yourself
up for success you gotta love yourself
yeah feel that the way you guys I'm Izzy
welcome back round of applause
how's gosh I think my weakest point were
the theme that I started with I didn't
you do a reminder in the middle of the
cut yeah that was one of my weakest ones
which which is something I'm struggling
with to tie it continually in summer
classes I would do a little bit more but
consistently it wasn't like every 15-20
minutes it was that coming back coming
back to it I think that the huddle with
the helpers was really good you weren't
there for it but did that super fun I
was really much more on honest and
vulnerable time like guys I love you
this is something important that we're
doing I really felt that like this was a
special thing which was great and I
finished with a high energy at the end
of class as far as I know like I didn't
let look like I didn't do the serious
story people deserve love and
buh-buh-bah and stop it there if you're
going to make a commitment Judah woohoo
- the whoohoo and it's like raising it
up so leaving it on a high which is nice
and so some of the students are like I'm
really looking forward to my Mondays and
the LA okay
tonight's reinforcements my 5mm boy oh
yeah yeah - the previous classes the
next classes yes yeah yeah yeah when I
was a student I wish that more people
would tell me words of encouragement
words of sincerity so I'm happy to do
two things and you give me a whoohoo for
that commitment the first thing I
already mentioned as usual you guys want
to people from the level one class of
coming in and get in - give them a
loving high pot 1 1 that's 1 - if you
love what you did right here I want to
just go find one person outside of this
class and give them that low and make
them feel special right the more we
spread that love the more you spread of
generosity
honestly it always comes back to us
doesn't it when we're kind and we are
loving to others it always comes back
why I am only here because you care
about the environment that I create
you're like I want to go to Alex's class
that are like it's the only class that's
being taught one or the other but if not
it's not I can see you're smiling and
see enjoying it I love you guys so just
one person you're going to make those
two commitments for me okay there are
some nights that are the best night that
he's ever done like that is amazing
and then will fall back for the next two
or three weeks why are you not more
consistent it's one of my weakest thing
so maybe I'm avoiding it it's part of it
you haven't had a perfect class you had
moments of greatness in each of your
different classes
BMS perfect class that you've already
done all of this stuff you've already
done all of it yeah you can do it you
know if you can if you stayed at that
high level he'll grow super quick and
there'll be a point where I don't I
won't know what to tell anymore Ryan you
have to find another mentor and have to
continue to seek out other expertise or
the help you need to grow and I think I
think that also you know maybe scares
them a little bit because I want
feedback I want that even if it does
even if it's like the next three weeks
like alex is the same thing I don't care
I'm like I'm trying I'm trying in some
way to improve it you might not be
seeing it but I'm thinking about it I
can't not continue to grow not continue
to get feedback it's important pain is
good like what I'm feeling right now
that discomfort is a good thing it makes
me want and more makes me value it more
and it makes me better if you take the
heart that he has an energy and passion
he has and match it to the behaviors
that he has shown and wants to be its
that's an unstoppable force there's
still yes room to grow but just doing
what he's capable of on a consistent
basis is insane and so he sees that he
wants that his past behaviors haven't
been like that until he wants to you
want to do it you know like he's just on
the cusp of making a huge breakthrough
as a leader as somebody who people would
look up to and respect and want to
follow and so this was the first this is
like the the opening of the kimono this
is the starting point for him and I'm
just hoping that people see the amount
of care and love and attention to detail
and heart that goes into each class that
he puts on
when there's gonna be different expanded
phrase in the bar raising the bar and
the already back soft instructive panda
I'll get there okay okay anything else
no oh come on thank you I don't know I I
think that one of my limiting beliefs
was that to be a good leader you have to
be stoic I thought you have to be strong
for people to respect you gotta be you
know got to make a decision you got to
do it like that and this is how you do
it what I'm learning is the
vulnerability actually there's a lot of
strength to it and people can feel more
open when you're vulnerable
and people don't respect you any less if
you say that you're working on something
you're trying to get better I think
maybe it's like a middle school
mentality you think you're different and
people will pick on you know want to sit
but everyone as you get older it's funny
you go through so much drama so much
difficulty you realize that everyone
goes through this and so when you share
that most people like yeah I've been
through that too yeah I've been there
too right you have kind of that
awareness in general or maybe I'm just
fortunate that environment I'm in I have
that 1145 I've been up since 7:45 spend
1415 hours these are a lot of my date
it's worth it it is so worth it when I
see people smiling when I see people
having a great time
when I see that I'm building something
bigger the bigger than what most people
can even imagine
it's worth it but there's one lesson is
that take a chance on yourself and going
all-in go all-in on what you love and
you will always come out and space and
people with the hard work in the lovin
foot I was the best dancer Evan didn't
think I could be a good instructor I
took a chance on this when I had other
career options couldn't be happier I
choose myself I have I had a nice spa
job right now I work 14 hours and I'm
grateful and I'm happy I think that's
what you have to decide lots of money
you get how many hours you put in it's
following your passion and check out the
courage to do it
the gorches do it so go out and figure
it out and if you're on a dance floor
maybe I'll be able to help you with that
I want our space to be about more than
dancing I think that a lot of dance
schools or in general businesses they
focus on just the product that they're
trying to do or the service or whatever
it is dancing is a means and my big
vision for tedious is when people come
in for the lesson they might not
expected but they grow us people and
they they get to last more and they get
to be more confident about themselves
and it gets to be more loving and they
get to take that into their personal
life and they feel good about themselves
and they make the people around them
feel good about themselves I don't know
why I'm getting emotion this is really
weird but I feel really strongly that
PDF has done a huge amount for my life
and the transformation that I've gone
through and the hard work that I've put
in doesn't say dance like I worked on
the dance awesome but it doesn't say
dance says family there and so when you
come in it the intention that it's more
than just that you're part of a
community you're part of something
and I think that speaks really deeply to
everybody we're all tribal no man is an
island and we all want to feel that we
belong and at my core my core value my
one word is belong that's the thing that
I was looking for a very long time in
high school and university a place where
I wouldn't be judged a place where I
feel that I'm enough
yes everyone tries to improve and tries
to grow as a dance you want to grow as a
human being you're enough and I don't
think that we get that at work sometimes
with our friends with our colleagues
with our family it's all and then so you
get all this all this coming at you all
the judgment all this you're not quite
fitting in or this or that sometimes
it's with yourself and you just don't
feel fit in with yourself you don't feel
like you deserve it and that's cruel
that that's that's that's so isolating I
don't I want I want something better at
GDS I want I want I want people to feel
like they belong they don't need to be
the best dancers they don't need to get
only 2x to keep moves perfectly I will
get them wherever they want to get as a
dancer they just need to love themselves
and have a great time smile and meet
some new people write a couple's connect
hug each other love each other because
in 50 60 years time when I'm lying on my
deathbed I'm looking at my life I'm
never going to remember that I executed
some move perfect you don't remember
that but I'm going to remember if
someone broke down in my class and cried
because I said something that really hit
home for them and that's happened reason
that's happening I'm noticing that I'm
saying things that are hitting people in
the heart and like touching them like
that letting them have an environment
where they can be vulnerable really
vulnerable that is incredible and that
is something that I'm very grateful for
and so I want that for TDs I want I
would love that TDS is in a bunch of
locations across the state
across Canada where we are giving that
message right that we are saying that
yes you are enough you should love
yourself it doesn't matter if you have
to look deep you come to us and we will
show you actually that you're not half
full or half empty
you are completely full you just missing
it you just not seeing it so we're going
to create an amount where it's loving
and you're going to realize how much you
have inside you so that's what I want
fifty is short yeah it feels weird feel
they're talking like this but I get
emotional because it's important to me
it's important to manage I think it's a
I think it could make the world a better
place if more people felt that they
belong powerful yeah
you